add sparks to high temperatures and high
winds across a landscape that's had
years of drought and you get this what
authorities are calling an unprecedented
emergency more than ninety two separate
bush fires of those many are out of
control
the devastating and horrific fires that
we've seen particularly in New South
Wales but also in Queensland have been
absolutely chilling and I want to thank
all of those who have fought so bravely
overnight and out there still today I
also want to thank all of those who are
backing them in and supporting them more
than 1,000 firefighters are tackling the
blazes most are volunteers
driving through scenes like these 60
aircraft are helping two of them are
large tankers dumping retardant to try
and dampen the flames but already more
than a hundred and fifty homes have been
lost and people have died and it's
feared more will as we stand today there
are more than 70 fires burning across
the state more than 40 uncontained and
at least five an emergency level Port
Macquarie is a major town on the New
South Wales coast smoke fills its air
the sky is orange debate is fierce in
Australia as to whether these fires are
a direct result of manmade climate
change the government says not but fires
are getting more frequent and more
intense in Australia and seem to get
earlier each year it's not even summer
here yet
temperatures will drop a little on
Sunday and stay lower on Monday but it
will be temporary relief the heat will
return on Tuesday and there's no
forecast at all for rain Andrew Thomas
al Jazeera Sydney